völlig erschöpft nach ihrem einsatz in
den schrecklichen waldbrandgebieten im
us bundesstaat oregon
diese feuerwehr helden der russe in
ihren gesichtern und auf ihren uniformen
so haben sie 14 stunden am stück gegen
die flammen gekämpft und sie geben sich
gegenseitig kraft und hoffnung mit
diesem lied 20 erschöpfte
feuerwehrmänner sie singen auf die
melodie von take me out oder ball game
holt mich hier raus zum ballspielen seit
knapp zwei monaten sind sie im
dauereinsatz im kampf gegen die
verheerenden brände an amerikas
westküste tausende zehntausende menschen
haben dort inzwischen ihr zuhause
wir haben alles verloren wir haben
versucht viele sachen mitzunehmen haben
aber nicht gedacht dass die zerstörung
so groß sein würde
und dann dann mussten wir vieles hinter
uns lassen ich konnte meine familie und
mein hund wenigstens noch retten es ist
einfach schrecklich und die feier sie
kommen weiter einfach nicht zur ruhe
schon mehr als 20 milliarden dollar
schaden haben diese brände in den usa
verursacht 35 menschen wurden dabei
bisher getötet und dutzende vermisst
gebraucht wird alles was kraft gibt und
hoffnung sowie das lied der mutigen
feuerwehrmänner von oregon
bild wollte die helden kennenlernen und
es und es ist gelungen einen
feuerwehrmann ausfindig zu machen wir
konnten mit ihm sprechen über seinen
arbeitsalltag aber auch über seine
ängste
hier stehen zirka um sechs uhr morgens
auf packen unsere sachen und
kontrollieren unsere taschen laden
wasser und mittagessen auf ich gehe dann
zum briefing während die crew frühstückt
wir setzen uns in die trucks fahren den
hügel wir haben fünf kettensägen die
fast den ganzen tag laufen
der rest der 13 männer benutzt werkzeuge
um dem boden des waldes oder wo auch
immer wir gerade sind von brennbarem
material frei zu schaufeln um zu
verhindern dass das feuer sich
ausbreitet unser job ist es also
brennmaterial aus dem weg zu schaffen um
dem feuer die ausbreitung möglichkeit
zum meine größte angst ist dass ein baum
umstürzt und einen meiner männer
herrscht manche träumen von den häusern
die wir nicht retten konnten von den
dingen die wir gesehen haben
ich bin kein therapeut aber ich weiß da
sind teile in mir die nie wieder so sein
werden wie früher wegen der dinge die
ich während der arbeit als feuerwehrmann
erlebt haben